...
-Ce soir,
..j'irai danser le mambo,
..au Royal Casino..
..sous les lambris rococo.
La pluie..
..viendra me faire oublier.
Tu me feras rêver,
..comme les chansons d'été.
C'est l'amour à la plage.
Et mes yeux..
..dans tes yeux.
Baisers et coquillages.
Entre toi et le bleu.
...
La mer,
..quand vient
le temps des vacances,
..c'est le temps de la danse,
..entre tes bras,
toutes les nuits.
Et si..
..j'ai le coeur tout retourné,
..là, je t'embrasserai..
..jusqu'à la fin de l'été.
C'est l'amour à la plage.
Et mes yeux..
..dans tes yeux.
Baisers..
..et coquillages.
Entre toi et le bleu.
Yeh eh eh !
Hou hou !
Hou hou ! Hou hou !
Yeh eh eh !
Et si..
..j'ai le coeur tout retourné,
..là, je t'embrasserai..
..jusqu'à la fin de l'été.
C'est l'amour à la plage.
Et mes yeux dans..
..tes yeux.
Baisers et coquillages.
Entre toi et le bleu.
C'est l'amour..
..à la plage.
Et mes yeux
dans tes yeux.
Baisers et coquillages.
Entre toi et le bleu.
C'est l'amour à la plage.
Et mes yeux
dans tes yeux.